the Democratic piranhas tear each other
apart so president Trump decides hey why
not jump into the water and ice concerns
hit fever pitch I'm Ben Shapiro this is
the Ben Shapiro show well the first rule
of politics is don't stop your enemy
when they're in the middle of making a
mistake but president Trump breaks all
the rules man that's just the way he
rolls I know that there may not be a lot
of World of Warcraft fans here in the
ben shapiro show audience but i do need
to make a reference that requires
explanation so there is a game an online
game called world of warcraft it is a
multiplayer game apparently I'm not a
World of Warcraft player myself and all
of the although there's one very famous
meme that has come from World of
Warcraft in which a bunch of people who
are all playing World of Warcraft
together are sitting around planning
their next move and one of the players
is away from his computer preparing
himself a plate of chicken he comes back
and they are all still preparing their
plan and he decides to randomly charge
directly into the middle of a firefight
thus killing everyone while shouting
Leroy Jenkins well this is President
Trump again the news cycle this weekend
could have been the Democrats tearing
each other apart the news cycle could
have been this weekend people attempting
to raid a nice facility and one guy
getting killed while attempting to
destroy a nice facility all of that
could have been the new cycle this
weekend instead the news cycle was Leroy
Jenkins the President of the United
States deciding to tweet xenophobic
nonsense in the middle of a democratic
in fight and to do so in such a way that
the Democrats were able to unite against
him this is so intensely stupid it is
almost impossible to overstate how
stupid this is and on a political level
on a moral level it is
idiocy of the highest order now does
this mean that the people whom President
Trump is attacking are suddenly godsends
that they are wonders to the United
States no that's the point the point is
that a targeted a targeted political
attack on Ilhan Omar would be will too
well taken she's a terrible Congress
person with terrible ideas or
alternatively shut up and let the
Democrats do it because here's where we
when last we left our story last Friday
when last we left our story Nancy Pelosi
and AOC were in the middle of a massive
firefight with one another and it was
glorious as a conservative it was
glorious to watch all of the specters
all of the all of the ghosts of
Christmas past the intersectional ghost
of Christmas past come back to haunt
Nancy Pelosi it was wonderful because
Nancy Pelosi had enabled this
intersectional nonsense for years on end
proclaiming that everyone who disagreed
with the Left agenda was a racist and it
had come back to bite her directly on
her posterior thanks to AOC and her crew
and meanwhile she was going after AOC -
and everybody was going after everybody
and then Leroy Jenkins appeared
president Jenkins and he decided to
insert himself will explain exactly how
all of this played out since last week
and why on a political level it's it's
moronic and beyond that why on a moral
level it is it is bad stuff of
relatively high order we'll get to that
in just one second first let me tell you
I wear movement sunglasses I we're
moving sunglasses because they are
awesome
that's not the only movement product I
wear elsewhere a movement what they have
sunglasses they have watches of all
sorts of great stuff that are not gonna
cost you a fortune and they are
high-quality and the MT sunglasses
started 60 bucks no pair of prices over
95 bucks so you're guaranteed to find a
style you love with quality that doesn't
break the bank they've sold over 2.5
million products across more than 160
countries their collections are always
expanding get 15% off today with free
shipping and free returns by going to
MVM t-dot-com slash shapiro see why the
movement keeps growing check out their
expanding collection I love movement
products I have movement products and my
wife has moved in sunglasses and a
movement watch my parents have movement
watches they really are first-rate this
is a company that started really small
and it's gotten really large and they're
undercutting all of their competition by
selling direct to you so go to MDM
t-dot-com slash appear oh that's
movement comm slash repair it's
minimalist style really classic styling
and all of it is really durable stuff
dude go check them out at movement comm
slash capiro MVM t.com slash shapiro for
sunglasses watches and everything else
get 15% off with free shipping and free
returns when you use that promo code MVM
t.com slash apparel okay so let us
review this all began when Nancy Pelosi
she spent basically the last seven
months
vacillating between praising a OC for
her supposed energy and brilliance and
and knocking aoc as a dolt who doesn't
know the hell she's doing who's too
radical who attacks moderate members of
the Democratic caucus
it was criticism like this that we're
about to hear from Nancy Pelosi that led
ALC to strike backs this began with
Nancy Pelosi attacking AOC and
suggesting that a glass of water would
win a OCS district if it had a D on it
which of course is true we won this
election it wasn't in districts like
mine or Alexandria's however wonder and
she's a wonderful member of Congress I
think all of our colleagues will attest
but those are districts that are solidly
Democratic this glass of water would win
with a D next year in those districts
and not to not to diminish the the
exuberance and the personality and the
rest of Alexandria and the other members
okay
the exuberance is wonderful but they're
idiots is what Pelosi saying well this
caused AOC to get mad and then she told
The Washington Post quote when these
comments first started I kind of thought
that she was keeping the progressive
flank at more of an arm's distance in
order to protect mamada remembers which
I understood but the persistent singling
out it got to a point where it was just
outright disrespectful the explicit
singling out of newly elected women of
colors now she is calling out Nancy
Pelosi as a racist the reason Pelosi is
attacking AOC or Ayane Presley who again
is the Ringo Starr of the of the squad's
Beatles or L hon Omar or she did sleep
the reason that Pelosi is attacking
those people is not because they are so
radical that they are undercutting
Democratic appeal in the middle of the
country she's not attacking them because
they're adults who don't know how
Congress works and publicity hounds who
are interested in the nearest camera now
the reason the Pelosi is attacking AOC
according to AOC is because Bulow's he's
a racist and all of us on the river like
yes yes make the magic happen drew it
let them fight right this is this is
what we were waiting for we were waiting
for the moment when the intersectional
caucus came for old Nancy Pelosi in the
same way that the intersectional caucus
is coming for Joe Biden and then ALC up
the ante she suggested that Nancy Pelosi
was responsible for death threats
against AOC and Ilhan Omar and receded
Talib and Ayana Presley
or individuals and knowing the media
environment that were operating in
knowing the amount of death threats that
we get knowing the amount of
concentration of attention I think it's
just it's it's worth just worth asking
why do you think she has racial animus
is she raised Oh No absolutely
no no I'm walking away by kindness she's
racist so that all leads to the CBC the
Congressional Black Caucus then firing
back on a OC and her squad on behalf of
Nancy Pelosi why well because psychotic
labardi is the chief of staff for AOC
some say AO C's brain and he has spent
the last several months attacking the
quote-unquote New Democrats Southern
Democrats many of whom are black and who
happened to be more moderate in
orientation on some of the policy issues
that AOC is pushing so you originally
tweeted out that these New Democrats
were like 1940 style Jim Crow Democrats
even though many of them are black and
then he retracted that and then he
tweeted out didn't realize this needed
to be said but you can be someone who
does not personally harbor ill will
toward a race but through your actions
still enable a racist system and a lot
of New Democrats and Blue Dogs did that
today this is in reference to my
comparing Blue Dogs and New Democrats to
1940 Southern Democrats Southern
Democrats enabled to race his system to
I have no idea how personally racist
they all were and we're seeing the same
dynamic play out now so he was out there
her chief of staff calling the other
Democrats a bunch of vicious racists in
the mold of the Southern Democrats who
are enabling a racist system why because
they voted for additional funding for
ice so that ice could do its job and
ensure that people who are crossing the
border illegally weren't being penned up
in cages 22a room and as it turns out
it's not enough funding anyway so
psychotic were barred he was attacking
all of these other certain so-called New
Democrats
well this then led the house Democratic
accounts on Twitter this was Friday the
house Democratic account which
apparently is handled by Hakeem Jeffries
a Democrat from New York he tweeted out
who is this guy and why is he explicitly
singling out a Native American woman of
color and the reason that that this is
being brought up is because Chakrabarti
also tweeted I think the point still
stands I don't think people have to be
personally racist to enable a racist
system and the same could even be said
of the Southern Democrats
I don't believe Charisse is a racist
person but her votes are showing her
Abell erases system whose her friend -
Cherise David's right congresswoman
Charisse David's voted in favor of ice
funding so Hakeem Jeffries tweeted out
on behalf of the entire house Democratic
caucus apparently who is this guy and
why is he explicitly singling out a
Native American woman of color her name
is congresswoman David's not Charisse
she's a phenomenal new member who
flipped a red sea blue and then with the
with the black colored hands emojis the
clapping emojis keep her hand out of
your mouth oh well you know that they've
they've gotten fire of the House
Democrats when they start using that
clapping emojis clapping emojis are in
the left a sign of seriousness you use a
fighter emoji or a clapping emoji this
means you are SuperDuper SuperDuper
pooper scooper serious on the left if
you start using those sorts of emojis so
they're using the emojis on a sec chief
of staff and it appeared that this was
all coming to a head it appeared and the
Democrats were all gonna go directly
after Chakrabarti they won't can go
after a Oh Sikhs they can't do anything
about a oh say then we're gonna go
directly after Ilhan Omar who after all
just two months ago they defended even
though she's a rabid anti-semite they're
gonna go after Chakrabarti and knock him
off and by knocking off Chakrabarti who
is allegedly a o C's brain they were
basically going to render aoc feckless
and the funked and then that caucus
would basically disappear from the front
pages because let's face it
Ilhan Omar and Rasheeda Talib are not
nearly as media attractive as AOC is
which is why AOC gets all the attention
in a second we'll explain how this was
getting even worse for AOC and the squad
and how they were fighting back until
Leroy Jenkins arrived explaining just
one second first losing hair it's not
fun two out of three dudes will
experience hair loss by the time they're
35 years old introducing keeps the
easiest most affordable way to keep the
hair you have these fda-approved
products used to cost a lot but now
thanks to keeps they're finally
inexpensive and easy to obtain for five
minutes now starting at just 10 bucks
per month you're never gonna have to
worry about hair loss again you should
take a lot off your mind considering
that if you got hair loss running in
your family you kind of sit there
worrying every day how much hair am i
losing and it's never coming back
getting started is super easy signing up
takes less than five minutes just answer
a few simple questions snap some photos
to complete your online doctor
consultation a licensed physician will
review your information online recommend
the right treatment for you and then
it's shipped directly to your door every
three months
keeps treatments are up to
percent effective at reducing and
stopping further hair loss only ten
bucks to 35 bucks a month plus now you
can get your first month for free that's
a hell of a deal for keeping your hair
as you know hair loss runs in my family
and there is a reason that keeps should
be on the front of your mind if you
suffer from hair loss the last thing you
need is to wait to see a doctor with
keeps there's finally a way to get to
help when you need it for a limited time
get your first month of treatment for
free to go to keeps calm / Ben if you
suffer from hair loss get that first
month of treatment for free go to K EEP
Escom / Ben keeps calm / Ben okay so
this gets even worse for the squad
Congressional Black Caucus member
Gregory Meeks Meeks ripped into the
Justice Democrats who are led by
Chakrabarti and aligned with AOC they
started attacking them just in the last
few days right and and they were going
after them hard so the Justice Democrats
were backing primary challengers to
eighth term representative Henry Cuellar
of Texas a Hispanic Caucus member and
tens firm representative William lacy
clay of Missouri who's a member of the
CBC they were also talking about
challenging the Democratic caucus
chairman Hakeem Jeffries who of course
hates them and he of course is seen as
an heir apparent to Nancy Pelosi and he
is also the person who's in charge of
that House Democrats account that was
attacking Chakrabarti well this prompted
Gregory Meeks a senior CBC member to say
quote it just seems strange that the
Social Democrats seem to be targeting
members of the Congressional Black
Caucus individuals who have stood and
fought to make sure that
african-americans are included in part
of this process I don't know what the
agenda is but if they want to come after
members of the Black Caucus it's two
ways meaning that we are going to if
they're either going to win or they're
going to lose a lot of folks very upset
with the Justice Democrats so all this
was breaking out into the open all of
this was wonderful and aoc swing then
came to her defense so Ilhan Omar then
came to her defense she was appearing at
Netroots nation which is a conference of
crazy people on the radical left where
as we will see later in the program that
they actually performed fake abortions
on watermelons it's all good times over
at Netroots nation and Ilhan omar told
the crowd that lawmakers quote shouldn't
ask for permission or wait for an
invitation to lead in other words we're
not gonna listen to Nancy Pelosi
she said we recognize every single
person has a role our role is to take
our votes leadership's role is to
wrangle votes and so if everyone
understands what their role is
everyone succeeds that's omar saying
Nancy you stick to your job you stick to
wrangling our vote and you let us say
what we want she was also on a panel
alongside Ayanna Presley and Rasheeda to
leave again the Beatles of socialism
here and Omar said there's a constant
often struggle oftentimes with people
who have power about sharing that power
so that was her subtweeting at Nancy
Pelosi she said we're not really in the
business of asking for that share of
that power we are in the business of
trying to grab that power and return it
to the people so that is the the again
non moderate non rational ill Hanham are
trying to wrest control away from Nancy
Pelosi Ayanna Presley went even further
again Ringo Starr here of the of the
squad she at Netroots Nations she again
attacked the Congressional Black Caucus
and she said listen here's what we don't
need we don't need black people who
don't know that they're black or gay
people who don't know that they're gay
we need people who think exactly like
Ayanna Presley does because Ayanna
Presley is the greatest expositor of
what it means to be black or gay or
Latino or whatever she knows what it is
to be a true member of the
intersectional community here is Ayanna
Presley launch attacks on Democratic
leadership for whatever lived experience
an identity that you represent if you
are not prepared to come to that table
and so represent that voice don't come
because we don't need any more Brown
faces that don't want to be a brown
voice we don't need black faces but
don't want to be a black voice we don't
need Muslims that don't want to be a
Muslim voice we don't need queers that
don't want to be a queer voice okay and
everybody cheering because everybody's
crazy over at Netroots nation who in the
Democratic caucus is she talking about a
black person who doesn't want to be
black or a queer person who doesn't want
to be queer she's allowed to use that
word I guess so I guess we're all he led
to use the word in that context okay
fine this is this is the Democrats
tearing each other apart and then Karen
attea who's the global opinions editor
over at the Washington Post she tweets
out what people need to see in this
newly formed Maureen Dowd
speaker Pelosi Donald Trump axis of evil
is that white supremacy relies on
dismissing
silencing and undermining women of color
putting them in their place by any means
necessary I mean this thing was out in
the open that is the global editor of
the Washington Post editorial page
saying that Maureen Dowd and Nancy
Pelosi and real Donald Trump that's his
Twitter account they're all on the same
page they're all white supremacists
they're all way too premises it's a hot
take man and all Trump had to do was sit
back and be quiet and it got even better
because Maureen Dowd then decided to
join the fight so she's referenced in
that Karen attea to 8:00 she had a piece
in the New York Times on Sunday in which
she was talking about the internecine
warfare between Nancy Pelosi and AOC she
says quote I was feeling on edge writing
a column that sparks an intern a scene
fight among the highest-profile women in
the Democratic Party is nerve-racking so
I went to the gym
Alex tweets on the digital peloton
instructor inside the screen on my
spinning bike had some wisdom for me the
kind of New Age bromide dispensed in
spin classes everywhere it climbed the
mountain to see the world you don't
climb the mountain so the world can see
you I only wished AOC was cycling
alongside me to hear it as well AOC
ensorcelled me from the start I love the
bartender makes good Cinderella story
the shake-up the capital idealistic
dreams the bravado about how the
plutocrat president from Queens wouldn't
know how to deal with a Puerto Rican
girl from the Bronx she's not from the
Bronx and I imagined the most potent
feminist partnership in American history
Nancy Pelosi essence' bringing her
inside game and AOC the karate kid with
a wicked Twitter game but instead the 79
year old speaker in the 29 year old
freshmen are trapped in a generational
an ideological tangle that poses a real
threat to the Democrats ability to beat
Donald Trump next year
Pelosi told me after the aoc Squad voted
against the houses version of the border
bill and trashed the moderates the very
people who provided the Democrats the
majority that the squad was four people
with four votes she was talking about a
legislative reality if it was a knock it
was for abandoning the party that did
not merit a oh C's outrageous accusation
that Pelosi was targeting newly elected
women of color she slimed the speaker
who spends her life fighting for the
downtrodden and who was instrumental in
getting the first african-american
president selected and passing his
agenda against all odds as a sexist and
as a racist aoc says Maureen Dowd should
consider the possibility that people who
disagree with her do not disagree with
her color glad to see the left come
around on this one gang that's entertain
glad to see the left finally realize oh
wait a second if I think AOC is just
stupid then maybe it's because I think
she's stupid not because of the color of
her skin cuz lots of people with lots of
different colors of skin are incredibly
stupid as we will see in just a second
we'll continue with Maureen Dowd's
column this was all what was the news
cycle this was the news cycle okay but
this is where the news cycle was we'll
get back to it in just one second with
that it's time for a wake up call with
black rifle coffee today I am drinking
the light roast from black rifle coffee
I'm not man enough for their dark roast
the black rifle coffee gang their coffee
is first-rate there is nothing quite
like black rifle coffee when it comes to
giving you a kick in the pants with tons
of different roasts to choose from black
rifle ships the best roast to order
coffee directly to your door and a
portion of all black rifles profits go
to supporting veterans law enforcement
fire first responder causes when a drink
black rifle coffee you're supporting a
company that gives back to veteran and
first responder causes and serves coffee
and culture to those who truly love the
country get your wake-up call with black
rifle coffee don't get any of that
watered-down stuff from the companies
that are interested in pander ins the
social justice left instead visit black
rifle coffee calm slash Ben get 20% off
your first purchase it's black rifle
coffee calm
/ ban for 20% off that first purchase I
know the folks who run black rifle
coffee not only is the coffee awesome
sort of the dudes who run a black rifle
coffee Marine whose veteran created and
veteran run it is awesome black rifle
coffee calm / man go check them out
right now black rifle coffee calm so I
spend you're not gonna regret it it is
definite up right over whatever you're
drinking right now black rifle coffee
calm / man okay so maureen dowd
lamenting the fight between AOC and
Nancy Pelosi she says the only lawmaker
went further implying that the speaker
was putting the squad in danger ask him
why Pelosi would criticize them knowing
the amounts of death threats and
attention they get huh
AOC pulled back and said she wasn't
calling Pelosi a racist but once you
start that ball rolling it's hard to
stop
you know how topsy-turvy the fight is
when the biggest defenders of Pelosi who
has endured being a caricature of
extreme liberalism for decades our Trump
and the Wall Street Journal editorial
board the alt crew threw down a gauntlet
in a recent opinion piece in The
Washington Post by the intercepts Ryan
grim he wrote the win Pelosi and other
Democratic mandarins tried to keep the
image of the party centrist they are
crouching in
defensive posture they've been in since
the Reagan Revolution Corbin Trent
spokesman for AOC co-founder of Justice
Democrats said the greatest threat to
mankind is the cowardice of the
Democratic Party with the older
generation driven by fear and unable to
lead message Pelosi has passed her prime
except says Maureen Dowd she's not and
then there's the real instigator
psychotic repartee as I say all the guns
were out on psycho
I mean the sights were leveled at
psychotic or Barty as of 24 hours ago
that's a OHS he's 33 year old chief of
staff who co-founded justice Democrats
and brand-new Congress both of which
recruited progressives including AOC to
run against moderates and Democratic
primaries the former Silicon Valley
Bernie bro assumes he could apply
Facebook's mantra move fast and break
things it's one of the oldest
institutions in a country but says
Maureen Dowd Congress is not a place
where you achieve radical progress
certainly not in divided government it's
a place where you work at it and work at
it and don't get everything you want the
progressives act as though anyone who
dares disagree with them is bad not
wrong but bad guilty of some human
failing some impurity that is moral evil
that justifies their venom rahm emanuel
told me Chakrabarti is a snot-nosed Punk
who has no idea about the battle scars
Pelosi bears from the liberal fight
she's led what votes did you get Emanuel
said rhetorically challenging a Oasys
chief of staff you should only be so
lucky to learn from somebody like Nancy
who's shown incredible courage and was
twice returned the Democratic Party to
power we fought for years to create the
majorities to get a Democratic president
elected and re-elected and they're gonna
dither it away they've not decided
what's more important so they want to
beat Trump or do they want to clear the
moderate and centrist out of the party
you really think weakening the speaker
is the right strategy to get rid of
Trump and everything he stands for in
the age of Trump says Maureen Dowd there
is no more stupid proposition than that
Nancy Pelosi is the problem if a OC and
her pygmalions and acolytes decide that
burning down the house is more important
than deposing Trump they will be left
with a racist backward presidents and
the emotive emotional satisfaction of
their own purity so Maureen Dowd Long
Knives out for Chakrabarti Long Knives
out for a OC & L hon Omar and Rasheeda
Talib and Ayanna Presley and they're all
fighting back I mean this is the biggest
Democratic invite that I have seen in
recent memory and then it gets even
worse for the Democrats because it turns
out that over the weekend all of their
talk about ice actually results
in some pretty nasty side-effects some
pretty nasty SATs here a couple of
stories about what was going on over the
weekend so here's what's happening
really with Immigration and Customs
Enforcement what's happening is they're
overwhelmed at the border because
Congress has not provided them the
funding Congress has not provided them
the necessary funding because Democrats
do not wish to provide them the
necessary funding Democrats wish for
there to be a humanitarian crisis at the
border that would supposedly justify
releasing large numbers of people into
the interior of the United States
without keeping proper tabs on them so
that eventually they will be given
amnesty and become American citizens or
so that they can live illegally in the
country so over the weekend Mike Pence
went down to the border we'll talk about
that in just a second so Mike Pence
heads down to the southern border for a
visit and he looks at the migrant
detention centers in Texas he toured two
toward two Border Patrol facilities and
it was not great and Mike Pence made
clear that it was not great he sort of
gave a little bit of conflicting
testimony here the tour according to the
New York Times gave journalists covering
the VP a rare glimpse inside a Border
Patrol station near McAllen Texas where
they observed nearly four hundred men
crammed inside a cage with no space to
lie down no mats or pillows according to
pool reports before members of the news
media were ushered out of the facility
some of the detainees shouted they'd
been there for more than 40 days were
hungry and could not brush their teeth
one poor reporter described the stench
as horrendous some of the agents wore
face masks and said it was sweltering
inside the detention center which is
less than 10 miles from the Rio Grande a
river that divides the United States and
Mexico Mike Pence had this to say about
the situation on the border these
families are receiving compassionate
care in a proper environment and I asked
every one of those little children are
you being well taken care of and they
all looked at me and said yes see and
that that did my heart good it made me
proud but everyone even in that
temporary facility Pamela it's getting
three meals a day they're getting health
care they're getting hygiene and the
Customs and Border Protection is doing
their level best in an overcrowded
environment in a difficult environment
to address this issue but Congress has
got to act to make it possible for us to
reduce the numbers of
coming into our country illegally so CNN
juxtaposes obviously pence talking about
children and the treatment of children
with the treatment of adults which is
not exactly the same thing pence then
commented on the situation at the border
with regard to those adults right he
said I was not surprised by what I saw
and said I knew we would see a system
that was overwhelmed this is tough stuff
and this is the point the situation on
the border is bad and the reason that it
is bad is because Democrats do wish it
to be bad the Democrats wish to rip ice
they wish to portray ice as an Auschwitz
like situation they wish to portray
immigration and customs enforcement as
running concentration camps now those
are the words of Alexander Ocasio Cortez
Alyssa Milano the heart of the
Democratic Party she tweeted out a
picture of Mike Pence viewing these
detention facilities alongside a picture
of Heinrich Himmler viewing the
concentration camps which makes perfect
sense until you realize that Himmler had
everybody inside those camps gassed or
is everybody who's inside that cage will
eventually either become an American
citizen or be released back to their
home country which is not the same thing
at all and they would all be treated
better if Democrats would sign a damn
check to make sure that ice could do
what it needs to do and this becomes
obvious when you see members of ice
speaking publicly about this situation
so late on Friday there was a a hearing
about the situation on the border
representative Garcia was speaking with
a former ice head whose name is Holman
and he said he went directly after
representative Garcia he said you know
you're going after ice we're the ones
doing the hard work on the border what
the hell are you talking about mr.
Holman I'm a father do you have children
how can you possibly allow this to
happen under your watch do you not care
is it because these children don't look
like children that are around you I
don't get it first of all your comments
are disgusting I've served my time I
enjoyed myself I said my country 34
years well I've served my country with
34 years what I've been trying to do my
34 years serving my nation is to save
lives so for you to sit there and insult
my integrity in my love of my country
and for the impro children that's why
this whole thing needs to be fixed okay
and this is the truth right you want
Democrats are grandstanding on this
issue let's say suits Garcia Democrat of
Illinois and that was former ice
enforcement chief Tom Holman who is
testifying on all of this well this was
leading to this grand rift between the
right and the left on ice where
Democrats are basically now claiming
that they want open borders and at this
and in order to achieve that open border
situation they want to make sure that
nobody gets funded so then nobody can
actually be held at the border and
processed in an orderly fashion
take for example hen Omar so the
representative radical representative
from Minnesota she was at Netroots
nation and she said we live in a society
and governed in a body that treats dogs
better than children right ripping into
Americans as racist and xenophobic and
terrible this the ice is is apparently
an emissary of evil here's Ilhan Omar
one of our members said to me if there
were dogs in those cages every single
member of Congress would vote to make
sure that all of these cages didn't
exist anymore so we live in a society we
live in a society and govern in a body
that might value the life of a dog more
than they value the life of a child who
might not look like theirs okay it's a
disgusting thing to say about the
country obviously we don't live in a
society where Americans value the life
of a dog over the life of a child of the
board it's insane why do you think
there's such outrage about what's going
on in the border why do you think that
everybody right left and center once
more funding at the border wants
something to be done that this is not
the situation at the border but the
Democrats are making that impossible
because at the same time that they are
claiming that they are deeply concerned
about the situation at the border people
like Ella Hannam are voting a she voted
against funding at the border she voted
against a five billion dollar bill that
was passed by the House Democrats to
fund the situation over at the border
and meanwhile you have top Democratic
officials like Mayor Eric Garcetti in my
hometown of Los Angeles suggesting that
illegal immigrants who are caught up in
ice raids immigration and customs
enforcement raids in his city will be
defended at taxpayer cost in Los Angeles
how do you explain this is full-scale
incentivization of open borders
is what Democrats were pushing over the
weekend no matter their immigration
status I want every Angelino to know
their rights and how to exercise them
remember you have the right to remain
silent
you don't have to open your door to an
ice agent that doesn't have a warrant
signed by a judge you have the right to
speak to a lawyer before signing any
documents or speaking to law enforcement
and if you need help finding an attorney
you can call 3-1-1 and learn more about
our justice fund and other resources
that offer legal support and most
importantly I want you to know you do
not mean be afraid your city is on your
side and rest assured here in Los
Angeles we are not coordinating the dice
right so I mean this is a major city
it's a hometown to a lot of folks who
are illegally immigrants illegal
immigrants here in the United States
obviously the Democrats are pushing a
radical agenda on the border so here are
the headlines over the weekend Democrats
pushing radical agenda on border
Democrats at war with each other and
then there were a couple of other
headlines that are get complete getting
completely ignored that have to do with
the immigration situation these would
have all been the headlines if the
president hadn't Leroy Jenkins to the
whole thing which we'll get to in just a
second I'll get to the morality of what
he had to say as well we'll get to all
that in just a second first nowadays
there are a lot of different types of
cars on the road there's no way the auto
parts store can stock everything why
would you wait in line to find the right
part that's probably overpriced when you
can do it all with the convenience of
Rock Auto rockauto.com is a family
business they serve Auto Parts customers
online they've been doing it for twenty
years go to Rock Auto comm shop for auto
and body parts from a hundreds of
manufacturers they've got everything
engine control modules brake parts
everything from that to tail lamps and
motor oil even new carpet whether it's
for your classic or daily driver get
everything you need and a few easy
clicks delivered directly to your door
best of all prices at rockauto.com are
always reliably low and the same for
professionals and do-it-yourselfers why
would you spend up to twice as much for
the same parts they've got amazing
selection reliably low prices all the
parts your car will ever need Rock auto
comm go-to Rock Auto calm right now see
all the parts available for your car or
truck right now in their how did you
hear about this box right shapiro so
they know that we sent you that helps us
it also helps them go to Rock Auto calm
right now see all the parts available
for your car or truck great selection
better prices right shapiro in there how
did you hear about us box so they know
that we saying you that's rock
dot-com okay we're gonna get to the rest
of the insane news cycle over the
weekend and president Trump's much
maligned and supremely covered tweets
we'll get to that in one second first in
a couple of things first you need to
subscribe over at say Lee Weyer calm
$9.99 a month ninety-nine bucks a year
you already know you get this the best
inventor beverage vessels get all extra
access to all sorts of great stuff that
we do including the daily wire backstage
and our Sunday special last week's was
Daniel Hanna news terrific also I want
to mention that Apollo 11 what we saw
episode two came out today so I
interviewed bill Whittle the host of
Apollo 11 what we saw last Friday on the
program and stuff I like and things I
like and the series is doing great
business I mean it's number three
overall on iTunes it really is true it's
beautifully produced bill does a great
job with it
episode 1 was already one of the highest
rated episodes on iTunes episode 2 came
out today as well if you haven't
subscribed go over to iTunes wherever
you listen to podcast SoundCloud
wherever you listen and you can
subscribe at Apollo 11 what we saw
episode two again out today go check
that out right now and again that helps
us bring you all sorts of content
including Apollo when you subscribe
brings all this content including the
Apollo 11 series all sorts of good stuff
happening over at daily water
we're the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast in the in the
nation
[Music]
you
well all the hubbub over immigration has
some pretty extreme stories associated
with it so I'm always hesitant to say
the rhetoric causes violence I'm always
hesitant to say it unless you are
explicitly calling for violence I don't
believe that you are the cause of that
violence unless you say go punch that
guy in the face I don't think that you
caused somebody to punch that guy in the
face if you say I don't like that guy
not the same thing if you say I think
that guy's a jerk not the same thing
even if you say I think that guy's a
racist not the same thing but what is
obvious is that the lack of any sort of
rational discourse happening around the
immigration situation is raising the
temperature and when you raise the
temperature you are going to get more of
the water spilling over the sides of the
pot and that's what you have over the
weekend over the weekend this is a story
that was wildly under covered how this
is not leading national news how
President Trump's Twitter is leading
national news is both a referendum on
President Trump's use of Twitter and on
the media's coverage of various issues
because you know it's a little more
important than whatever the president
tweeted today the fact that a man
attacked an ice detention center over
the weekend and then was fatally shot by
the police according to the New York
Times the police fatally shot a man who
was attacking an immigration detention
center in Tacoma Washington on Saturday
morning the authorities said imagine
that a right-winger had gone and
attacked at the IRS with a gun he they
might be leading the national news today
as opposed to whatever Obama tweeted
about it or Trump tweeted about it
instead the man who was armed with a
rifle was throwing unspecified
incendiary devices at the Northwest
detention center according to a police
statement the man was identified by
officials on Saturday we don't say the
names of people who commit these sorts
of terrorist acts 69 years old he's
Vashon Island Washington is where he's
from
he continued throwing lit objects at
buildings and cars one car was fully
engulfed in flames according to Officer
Loretta cool a spokeswoman for the
Tacoma Police Department he attempted
and failed to ignite a commercial size
propane tank attached to the center said
Shawn fallowed the resident agent in
charge of the Ice Office of Professional
Responsibility he said this could have
resulted in the mass murder of staff and
detainees housed at the facilities these
are the kinds of incidents that keep you
up at night officers arrived at 4:00
a.m. and called out to this would-be
shooter who's wearing a satchel and had
flares the statement said shots were
fired that resulted in his death
although officer cool could not say
whether he had opened fire this would be
shooter was declared dead at the scene
he died of multiple gunshot wounds
police have not established a motive for
the attack but according to his longtime
friend she said that he had intended to
provoke a fatal conflict he did release
apparently some sort of manifesto and in
the manifesto he suggested that ice
detention facilities were in fact
concentration camps that is the language
that he used it'll be it's fascinating
to watch as the media which have
declared over and over again
that if somebody in their manifesto uses
language that they can somehow connect
to President Trump that it's president
from fault but if somebody says
concentration camp and then goes and
tries to shoot up a nice facility then
presumably the rhetoric is still not
over charge will still get defense's
from the Washington Post of the rhetoric
from particular Democratic Congress
people who use exactly that kind of
rhetoric we've seen the same thing of
course during the Congressional baseball
shooting which would still be a national
story if Democrats had been the victims
of it but it was Republicans who are
attacked by a man who was basically
quoting Bernie Sanders at the time so he
didn't get any questions about how
rhetoric leads to violence that only
happens on one side of the aisle so that
was one incident over the weekend that
wasn't by the by the guy claimed
apparently in his manifesto that he was
a member of an Tifa five seconds ago the
media were defending an Tifa Seattle
apparently in in one of his Facebook he
put up a Facebook manifesto in which he
said quote I am an chief I stand with
comrades around the world
Seattle an tyfa put up an actual
statement about his deaths and when our
good friend and comrade took a stand
against the fascist detention center in
Tacoma he became a martyr who gave his
life to the struggle against fascism he
was kind and deeply loved by many
communities we cannot let his death go
unanswered so apparently more violence
coming from Seattle antiva throughout
history we idolize figures like John
Brown for their courage to take the
ultimate stand against oppression today
we stand strong in our support for yet
another martyr in the struggle against
fascism his death serve as a call to
protest and direct action direct action
of course is code for violence that was
not the by the way another hundred
people gathered today outside the
detention facility to protest because
this guy was shot after trying a violent
attack that was not the only attack on a
nice facility over the weekend there was
also a non-violent but trespass attack
and I
Detention Facility in Aurora Colorado
over the weekend according to the Denver
Post more than 2000 people had assembled
outside the ice detention facility in
Aurora on Friday night to protest the
Trump administration's planned
immigration roundups when Claudia
Castillo noticed a commotion a group of
protesters had broken through a chain
marked private property no trespassing
headed for the front of the detention
facility Castillo is a 22 year military
intelligence officer in the US Army and
legal services coordinator for the
Colorado immigrant Rights Coalition she
pled with the group of 25 that initially
pushed through didn't matter they then
pulled down an American flag from in
front of the facility they put up a
Mexican flag nothing says we believe in
America and America is not living up to
her standards quite like pulling down an
American flag and putting up a Mexican
flag on American sovereign territory
some people tried to burn the American
flag others spray-painted nasty words
about police we have a little bit of the
footage you can see them raising the
Mexican flag as people cheer up top this
ice facility nothing says that you
believe in America quite like replacing
the American flag with a Mexican flag
nothing says that you really are just
looking for the best for America in your
immigration policy quite like removing
an American flag and putting a Mexican
flag up top a a flagpole at a nice
detention facility after breaking in so
all of this all of this was the news
cycle the news cycle was Democrats
fighting each other it was an actual
violent attack on a nice facility by a
person claiming that it was a
concentration camp it was people who
were breaking into a nice facility to
pull down the American flag tried to
burn it and put up a Mexican flag that
was the news cycle over the weekend and
that's when President Leroy Jenkins
arrived to a president Trump decided
yesterday because apparently he was
bored and he was watching TV that he was
gonna tweet about things and what did he
decide to tweet about he decided that he
was gonna tweet about the Democratic
freshmen Congress women now he was not
specific hey if he had said that Ilhan
Omar doesn't seem to have proper
gratitude for the country that took her
in she seems to think this country was
founded and steeped in racism and
bigotry and homophobia and it's a
terrible place to be if he had said
basically what Tucker Carlson said last
week it would be controversial but it
wouldn't be what it is President Trump
did something else he tweeted out about
the quote-unquote progressive Democratic
Congress women without naming names and
then he suggested they should
back to their home countries there's
only one problem with this well they're
many but there's one big problem with
this only one of the so-called
progressive Democratic Congress women to
whom he is apparently referring actually
was born outside the United States I'm
gonna read you what President Trump had
to say word for word and then we'll
analyze what the defenders are saying he
said and then we'll talk about what
people are who aren't attacking him and
say that he said then we'll talk about
what he actually said so because there's
sort of three versions of this so here's
what President Trump tweeted he tweeted
so interesting to see progressive
Democratic Congress women who originally
came from countries whose governments
are a complete and total catastrophe the
worst most corrupt and inept anywhere in
the world if they even have a
functioning government at all now loudly
and viciously telling the people of the
United States the greatest and most
powerful nation on earth how our
government is to be run why don't they
go back and help fix the totally broken
and crime-infested places from which
they came then come back and show us how
it is done
those places need your help badly and
you can't leave fast enough I'm sure
Nancy Pelosi would be very happily happy
to quickly work out free travel
arrangements okay so the the defense of
President Trump goes something like this
when President Trump is saying is he's
not referring to a OC or Rashidah Talib
who was in fact born in the United
States
Oriana Presley who's born in the United
States he's referring to
Ilhan Omar and if he's referring to
anyone else he means that they should go
back to their failing districts and then
come back except that he says they
should go back to their home countries
because they all come from bad countries
and then they claim maybe he's just
talking about Ilhan Omar so why is he
saying progressive democratic
congresswoman or they referred to some
of the other Democratic congressmen
represent of jeyapaul for example who is
sort of loosely associated with the
squad except that he's pretty clearly
not talking about her cuz she hasn't
been hit by Nancy Pelosi anywhere in
here here is okay so that the the the
defense of him on its own merits that
he's not talking in scene a phobic terms
about people that fails then there is
the charge by folks on the left that
this is blatantly racist now I'm not
sure that it is racist I am sure that it
is xenophobic because what he's actually
he's not saying that people who are
brown are not from the United States he
is not saying that all people who are
brown and not looking like him are not
from the United States he's not saying
that all people who don't look like him
and who have darker skin who are
inferior what he is doing is he is
suggesting that a bunch of Congress
women of color with whom he does not
agree he is assuming they are not from
here which is more xenophobic point than
a racist one right he's basically saying
I don't like these women therefore they
must be foreigners therefore they must
not be from here now there may be a
racial tinge to it I think it's sort of
undeniable considering that these are
all women of color but it's more
xenophobic then I think in the racist
camp xenophobic pretty clearly now the
Democrats of course jumped on this so
there is the moral content of what he is
saying if you just said again
Ilhan oh my terrible congresswoman awful
ideas ideas that actually are unamerican
in many ways I think that's true I think
she says things that our own American on
a fairly regular basis I on American I
mean she says that the United States is
a terrible horrible no good very bad
place the American society treats
children like dogs you know or worse
than dogs I don't think that that is
particularly American stuff to say I
don't think that that means that she is
quote unquote a traitor I don't I'm not
going to accuse her of dual loyalty the
same way she accuses everybody else of
dual loyalty who disagrees with her I
will say that I don't think that her
rhetoric is is particularly patriotic
can we put it that way I think that's
fair if he attacks her that way I think
that's fine if he attacks her the way
the tucker carlson attacked ohio meyer
saying that she's a product of a failed
immigration system and she came here
with a series of beliefs about the
united states that don't that don't are
not properly appreciative of the united
states i think there's an argument to be
made it's it's dicey ER but i don't
think that that's racist or xenophobic
in and of itself but that's not what
from said instead he said progressive
congresswoman and he's referring to a
bunch of people including a bunch of
people who were born here and so he's
basically saying is if you disagree with
Nancy Pelosi and with me and if you are
radical and if you are brown then I'm
going to assume that you came from
somewhere else that's bad stuff okay
there's no way to slice that where that
is not bad stuff and it appears to be
bad stuff and it's also politically
idiotic hey there's no question it's
politically idiotic Ellison there'll be
people who defend president from saying
he's just attacking people who have bad
ideas again I have no problem with him
attacking aoc or Presley or to leave or
Omar all of whom I think are dumpster
fires of Congress people I think they're
all awful garbage Congress people with
awful terrible ideas I think ill ahead
Omar is one of the worst things to
happen to American Congress in a decade
I think that she is just
she's the worst Congress person that I
can remember since Cynthia McKinney
she's just taught she's terrible in
every way she's toxic but that attack is
wrong and it is wrong in a pretty
obvious way it is also politically
moronic because the Democrats are busy
attacking each other and president Trump
shouts we're or Germans and goes
charging right into the middle of a
firefight
so the piranhas are eating each other
the cannibalizing each other he's like
what if I just jumped in what if I just
you know like headlong right in this of
course resulted in exactly what you
would think it did it immediately like
that unified the Democratic caucus back
together again they put all of their
arguments with one another behind them
and Nancy Pelosi began tweeting about
how the president was a racist quote
when when Donald Trump tells for
American congresswoman to go back to
their countries he reaffirms his plan to
make America great again has always been
about making America white again our
diversity is our strength and our unity
is our power well you're not really
unified but now that Trump has said
something you can pretend to be I reject
Donald Trump's xenophobic comments meant
to divide our nation rather than attack
members of Congress he should work with
us for humane immigration policy that
reflects American values stop the raids
families belong together so again
president Trump immediately made the
Democratic caucus more cohesive again
absolute stupidity on every possible
level now I know people love his tweets
that's fine you can love his tweets that
doesn't mean that they are smart and
politically calibrated they certainly
were not it does not mean that the
series of tweets was good it was not now
I will also point out that the media do
not cover this stuff in any way the same
if it comes from the left or it comes
from the right if it comes from the left
then the media cover the Democrats signs
so now it's has every Republican come
out and condemn Trump what do they have
to say about Trump what did every
Democrat have to say about ohan Omar
what every Democrat have to say about
Rasheeda Talib every Democrat not only
went ahead with Rasheeda to leave in
ohon Omar they feeded them they patted
them on the back they gave him hugs they
passed a resolution condemning all hate
instead of anti-semitism so I'm not
gonna take a moral lecture from people
like Ilhan Omar and AOC about
intolerance that's not a thing that's
going to happen but it's not what about
ISM at the same time if you're going to
say President Trump said something wrong
why can't you guys condemn your own
people when they say something wrong the
Democrats never condemn anyone I
certainly understand the frustration of
folks on the right going why
do you think I'm gonna come out and say
anything when you guys won't say
anything I mean the answer is you say
something when something is wrong and
you shouldn't be making that decision
based on what the Democrats have to say
about their own people that's why you
are not a Democrat presumably but at the
same time there is certainly a double
standard and how this sort of stuff gets
covered Trump says something that is bad
everyone is all over him I think half
properly so not totally probably half
properly so when Democrats say stuff
that is wrong we get a bunch of think
pieces about how Democrats aren't
actually wrong okay time for some things
I like and then some things that I hate
so things that I like so I don't know if
you had a chance to watch at all
yesterday's Wimbledon final I was
heartbroken for Roger Federer Roger
Federer is in my opinion and the opinion
of most tennis observers the greatest
men's tennis player of all time he had
20 majors he should have won the match
yesterday frankly he choked and it's
hard to say that about a guy who you
really like but there's very little
doubt he chokes he was he had a match
point twice against Djokovic Djokovic is
incredibly versatile he's incredibly
durable and he's really tough minded so
Djokovic is at this point in his career
better than Federer there's I mean
Federer is on the downslope of his
career is nearly 38 years old Djokovic
is still only 32 he's got 16 majors but
the match itself went for five hours and
it was just incredible quality tennis if
Federer had had a little bit more he
pulls out this match he really won the
match pretty thoroughly he just lost in
the numbers so like Hillary Clinton it
doesn't matter if this thing gets
decided by the final score it doesn't
get decided by the quality of play
there's a little bit of the match you
can see it it's really first-rate yeah
you can just I mean these guys are
they're both so good and this is high
level quality competition and Federer is
is just terrific when he was in his
prime he was the best player who ever
lived I mean he was from 2003 to 2007
dude was basically unbeatable Djokovic
in the end because he's only 32 it's
possible that he ends up winning more
majors than Federer but he's catching
Federer on the downslope okay time for
some things that I hate
so let's talk about something a little
bit lighter but also similarly stupid
and that is the movies so Scarlett
Johansson is is now being ripped up and
down because she has suggested she
should be able to play various
characters one of the things the left
has done is they've basically decided
that you can only play a character if
you look like that character unless the
character was historically a white
character in which case we can make that
character whatever we want the character
to be so in other words if there was a
character who was black in the movies
and you make that character white that's
a problem if there's a character now who
is transgender and that character who's
transgender is played by a non
transgendered person that's bad but if
there was a character who was
historically white and then we make that
character non-white then that is a good
thing that is inherently good now
frankly I don't care about too much of
this in any case I'll explain why I
think that that is not true in the case
of James Bond not as far as color but as
far as sex um I'll explain that in just
a second but Scarlett Johansson got
caught up in all of this
so she said in a statement to variety
that she there was an interview that was
recently published she said it was
edited for clickbait and was widely
taken out of context she said the
question I was answering in my
conversation with the contemporary
artist David sally was about the
confrontation between political
correctness and art she said I
personally feel that in an ideal world
any actor should be able to play anybody
an art in all forms should be immunes
political correctness that is the point
I was making albeit it didn't come
across that way she then went on to
clear up some of the points made during
the original interview noting that not
every actor gets the same opportunities
as their Caucasian cisgendered
counterparts
she said I recognize that in reality
there is a widespread discrepancy
amongst my industry that favors
Caucasian cisgendered actors and that
not every actor has been given the same
opportunities that I have been
privileged to I continue to support and
always have diversity in every industry
and will continue to fight for projects
where everyone is included Johansson had
come under fire for her response to a
question about political correctness
because she'd been cast to play a
transgender woman named Dante Tex Gill
and in an upcoming film the film was
canceled after people started protesting
that she wasn't trans enough because it
turns out that Scarlett Johansson is a
beautiful a beautiful woman and like an
actual biological woman so this was a
weird controversy over the weekend in
which we were apparently supposed to
figure out exactly that we were so
post you suggest I guess that something
something deeply wrong had happened with
regard to Scarlett Johansson saying that
you should be able to play a variety of
parts okay so with that said there is
this new standard on the walk left and
again the standard is that Scarlett
Johansson cannot play a transgender
woman but you can recast James Bond as a
black woman now again I think this story
is being miss covered I don't think that
the Bond series has any intention of
making James Bond into a black woman I
don't think that's what's happening here
but there is news that is obviously
designed to elicit clicks and that is
that double-oh-seven
is going to be played by leshawna lynch
in the next movie
now double-oh-seven is a code name and
so you could be there been other movies
in fact where double-oh-seven is
temporarily taken somebody temporarily
takes the place of double-oh-seven and
then james bond becomes double-oh-seven
again right that has happened in the
movies before but the left was going
nuts over this they were so excited
about the possibility that an iconic
character like James Bond would suddenly
become black and female now I don't care
at all about the race of James Bond in
fact I don't think it's particularly
relevant to the part of James Bond in
fact I was kind of stumping for Idris
Elba to become James Bond I think he's a
terrific actor I love him in everything
I've ever seen him in and I think and he
was kind of stumping for it too I think
you'd make an excellent James Bond I
don't think the color has anything to do
with the part there are certain parts
where colour has something to do with it
right if you're watching Mississippi
Burning and gene Hackman's character is
black it makes no sense because color is
obviously part of the movie if you're
watching black panther and everybody's
white that doesn't make any sense
because color is obviously a part of the
movie and there's certain parts where
color is a part of the movie that is not
really true of James Bond maybe it was
true or back in like the nineteen if
you're setting it in the 1950s or 60s
when race is more of an endemic quality
to the to the social system but it's not
true today right you can have a black
action hero Denzel has been doing it for
thirty years forty years there there's
nothing new about that so having a black
guy play James Bond I think makes
perfect sense on an artistic level it
makes perfect sense on a narrative level
well makes no sense on an artistic or a
narrative level is having James Bond
played by a woman makes no sense at all
because as it turns out the natural
differences between black folks and
white folks are basically restricted by
most
data are basically restricted to the
color of your skin right I mean that's
what separates a black person from a
white person all the other standards are
somewhat malleable and move around
because who is black and who is white
even that is a standard that is somewhat
malleable that is not true for male and
female there are very very significant
differences between male and female and
that is particularly true in two
specific areas in which James Bond
actually has to be a man one in terms of
physical prowess and two in terms of sex
right James Bond is about two things
blowing things up and sex that's it
that's all James Bond is about James
Bond is a 17 year old boys fantasy and
there are a lot of 50 year old 17 year
old boys but that is that that is the
James Bond crowd that has always been
the crowd that's why Bond girls were
always seductive maidens and James Bond
special skill was it getting them into
bed now the left is celebrating because
they think for The Daily Beast has an
entire piece called leshawna Lynch a
black woman is taking over as
double-oh-seven it's about damn time
really why can't you just create a new
character who's a black woman and also
an action hero I mean that seems
plausible does it not is there a reason
why you have to take a traditionally
heterosexual hero like James Bond a
heterosexual man a very only
heterosexual man and then turn him into
a woman does that make any sense at all
The Daily Beast says in news that will
surely come as a shock to James Bond
fans in the film industry at large it
was revealed today that longtime
double-oh-seven Daniel Craig will pass
the Walther PPK to black British actress
leshawna Lynch in the iconic role for
years there's been intense speculation
about who would take over the reigns of
one of the most durable and profitable
film franchises in history once Craig
stepped aside much of that speculation
has revolved around whether the series
might make a nod toward diversity and
cast a person of colour or a woman for
the first time but if the report from
the UK tabloid The Daily Mail is to be
believed the double-oh-seven producers
are going for a radical twofer casting a
31 year old black female newcomer as
bonds a parent err well no that is that
is not actually what's going to happen
okay it is it is very very unclear where
where that this is going to be the
permanent replacement for James Bond in
all likelihood this this actress is
going to walk in play double-oh-seven
for five minutes and then be elevated to
the M
position perhaps or to a higher level
position where she is
bonds boss for example but the eagerness
with which left is greeting this
demonstrates they don't care very much
about art they care a lot about
political correctness particularly when
it comes to art so here is the problem
they made a movie with female James Bond
it was called atomic blonde and it
starred it starred Charlize Theron and
the movie is pretty good it's a pretty
good movie there's only one problem the
movie makes no sense on any level
because Charlize Theron is basically a
male character who is a female in other
words she beds beautiful women and she
is incredible in in terms of physical
conflict and all this and there's no
reason there's nothing about her
character that says okay she has to be a
woman if you replaced her with a man
then the movie would basically be
exactly the same and when it comes to
and that doesn't make a lot of sense in
terms of sexual dynamics the reason it
doesn't make a lot of sense is because a
lesbian relationship is not the same as
a heterosexual relationship men are
different than women that's not a
judgment of quality that is a judgment
of fact
okay there's it that's not a I'm not
saying better or worse even I'm just
saying that it is different any lesbian
will tell you the same I would assume
men and women are different and this is
particularly true with bonds so to take
a perfectly obvious example number one
there's this movie trope that 130 pound
soaking-wet woman can knock over a
200-pound man who is physically trained
that's absurd it's absurd in the extreme
one of the things about the Bond series
is that Daniel Craig is ripped beyond
belief and he can beat the crap out of
anyone and so that at least that part of
the movie is plausible if you're talking
about somebody who's a bowling ball of a
human going into other people and
breaking them up that makes a lot more
sense there's less suspension of
disbelief along those lines if it turns
out that the hero is actually physically
large and that is one aspect of James
Bond and then there's the other aspect
right cuz bond it's about the guns and
the girls when it comes to this
deduction of women if there is a very
very large difference between a woman
and a man I'm not gonna get into the the
lesbian aspect of this because I don't
know if this character is gonna be a
lesbian let's assume that she's not for
a second let's assume that she is just
black female James Bond which means that
she's betting the most handsome men that
is not in any way a wish fulfillment
fantasy for the men who typically
watched the Bond films because
disproportionate share of the Bond
audience is male
so mr. completely shifting the character
it makes no sense and also on a
narrative level makes no sense at all
because the challenge for James Bond to
be completely sexist about this okay the
challenge for James Bond is is conquest
right that's obviously been part of the
trope of the series is this conquest
driven mentality by James by now they're
trying to make it as though he has to be
in a relationship every movie because
they're trying to make it as though he
is not an abuser of women understood
okay but that was always the appeal of
bonnets in every movie he was going to
somehow seduce the most beautiful woman
in the movie into bed with him and this
is what made him an idol to millions of
men who of course would like to seduce
beautiful women but are incapable of
doing so because there's an actual
challenge to it now let's say that
there's a beautiful woman who is playing
James Bond like leshawna Lynch lets it
and now she wants to seduce the most
handsome man is that in any way
difficult because men and women are
different to quote the great
intellectual icon of our time Amy
Schumer Amy Schumer correctly said that
she can walk into a bar and catch a D
anytime she wants as her comedic line
that is true men okay there's a
difference in men and women when it
comes to sexual conquest men only need a
time in a place women need a reason and
to pretend that men and women are
exactly the same defeats part of the
narrative natural structure of the Bond
films but again we're supposed to ignore
all of that because it is very important
that we be woke and woken assumes that
men and women are exactly the same in
all these aspects which is again
silliness one of my favorite
sociological studies ever done has been
replicated several times there's a study
where professors took a attractive woman
in college aged woman and they had her
walk through a bar in a college town and
and proposition 100 men saying would you
like to come home with me at night over
seventy percent of the men said yes then
they replicated the experiment except
they had an attractive man walked
through a bar asking women would you
like to come home with me tonight
zero percent said yes zero is these
differences between men and women it's
one of the things that makes life
beautiful beautiful it was created by
evolution or God or both depending on
your perspective on this it is not
evolutionarily beneficial for
to be as sexually aggressive about
partnership as with as with men because
women historically and evolutionarily
speaking had a chance of getting
pregnant they wanted to be more
selective about the genetic material
that might provide a child men however
have a difference and contrary
evolutionary expectation which is to
reproduce with as many people as humanly
possible to pretend all of this crap
doesn't exist as the backdrops it's
something like bond is just silly
and the fact that the left is
celebrating all of this is is even
sillier art takes a backseat to
political correctness and you end up
with with absolute stupidity of the
highest order okay final thing that I
hate today
so Netroots as I have said is it as an
agglomeration of crazy and Lizz Winstead
is a comedy writer for Comedy Central
and she did a panel on abortion during
which one of the participants
demonstrated how to do an abortion on a
watermelon
she's the co-creator of The Daily Show
and a delight and in delight here she is
showing how to do an abortion on a
watermelon this is what you do over at
Netroots
and then we create such a pregnancy
and this doesn't work as well as it
would with the papaya but this is our
menus for about an eight week pregnancy
super go to hunting you go to eat
watermelon is the penis that's literally
bubble cheating and this is why we fight
to make sure that advanced practice
conditions
surgeries
basic healthcare
and basic health care it's easy to do
and safe and wonderful watch as we abort
this watermelon how nice well what the
lights they are over at Netroots can't
imagine why people think they're radical
really solid stuff already
movie back here later today for two
additional hours of content or we'll see
you here tomorrow I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Adam Savitz audio is mixed by
Mike Cora Mena hair and makeup is by
Jesuit alvera production assistant Nick
Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
19 hey everyone its Andrew Clavin host
of the Andrew Clavin show our president
Donald Trump is acting like a jerk again
the never Trump errs clutch their pearls
the pro Trump errs thump their chests
but with the Democrats swiftly becoming
an anti-american anti-freedom anti
prosperity party we need Trump to win in
2020 so it's wise to ask how much jerk
is too much jerk we'll ask on the Andrew
Clavin show I'm Andrew Clavin